nicht jeder hintern wird größer oder
kleiner aber mit der kniebeuge wird
jeder hinten runter und fester die
escort girl methode von nicolas steiner
getestet und selber praktiziert für
monate und entscheides live man könnte
vielleicht sagen beide betrachten den
körper als projekt und die prämisse ist
hierbei beiden büchern wie man sich
innerhalb der ansprüche die als gegeben
akzeptiert werden optimiert also dass
viel geld was gutes ist wird nicht
weiter hinterfragt oder dass ein sixpack
wünschenswert ist oder ein hintern genau
das erste setzt hingenommen und deswegen
strategien dazu entwickeln auch
niemandem besser entsprechende an wie
mer du deine entscheidung live
persönlichkeit liebs umso mehr wird dann
in einer kritiker dir positiv zu bilden
es geht viel weniger darum andere leute
zu unterstützen und es geht überhaupt
nicht darum die welt als ganzes besser
zu machen dass wenn ich es genau die
kritik auf einen punkt gebracht was ich
bei beiden büchern bemerkenswert finde
ist die selbstverständlichkeit in der
die ganze welt eingeteilt wird in gut
und böse
man soll sich nur mit den leuten treffen
die man mag oder die einen nutzen können
beruflich negative menschen vermeiden
dieser gedanke dass man menschen
überhaupt einteilen kann in eindeutig
negative und positive personen
impliziert dass es überhaupt keine
ambivalenten zwischenmenschlichen
beziehungen gibt jetzt würde ich aber
sagen der allergrößte teil menschlicher
beziehungen ist gerade durch ein
kuddelmuddel gekennzeichnet von
positiven und negativen aspekten und ich
mag hier nicolas steiner zum beispiel
sehr ich komme auch gerade darauf aber
einige sachen an ihr sind auch zum
weglaufen schlimm
trotzdem habe ich hier auf diesem hocker
aus ehrwald und das aushalten kann ich
kann das ja mal machen und mich als gott
geld betrachten also bei der escort girl
methode gibt es detaillierte pläne gute
proteine gute kohlenhydrate gute fette
luft heben seitlicher knieper
downloadbox blick
becker war dann sieht man so aus wie die
das ist schon echt ok ich meine ich
würde echt gerne so ausschauen wenn man
das durch macht kann man gar keine
berufstätige frau mehr sein also
zunächst mal ist das nicht notwendig so
dass man dann so aussieht zweitens
bewusst nämlich auch zeit investieren in
die optimierung der social media präsenz
fans heizen sie an durch die
belletristik kriegt man kein sixpack und
auch keine schöne frisur aber vielleicht
können wir uns darauf verständigen dass
das schlüsselwort eigentlich ist abstand
zu sich selbst zu ertragen dass es
bestimmte bereiche gibt in denen man
vielleicht jetzt nicht ganz vorne liegt
ich glaube es hat eher was mit sich
selbst wohlfühlen zu tun aber es geht
auch darum sich nicht so wichtig zu
nehmen ja du nimmst dich gar nicht
wichtig nehme ich überhaupt nicht
wichtig und werde ich noch weniger
wichtig nimmt als ich ist das motto wie
man sieht und damit enden wir